Okay, so what we are going to do in
this video is work together to get Twilio. Now,
I don't know about you, but downloading and installing
software from the Internet can sometimes be a very
painful process. Although it's still a very important part
of building cool apps. So, what we have done
here is, we have provided some documentation in the
instructor notes. And this documentation can guide you through
the installation of Twilio. By the way, after we
created these documents, we shared them with a whole bunch
of students and solicited feedback from those students. This
way, we were able to improve the quality of these
documents and now we feel really confident. That these
documents can help guide you through the entire installation process.
If you still have questions about the installation process,
however, feel free to ask us on the discussion forum.
We are here to help. So, at this point, I recommend that
you get these download instructions and
then install Twilio on your own computer.